citizens of the reject Nation after
months of requests and since uh I'm out
of town from the 12th to the 20th I
figured it's about time we answered the
call and I got my buddy Aaron Alexander
to join me today for this r r r
Aaron how are you I'm doing wonderful
I'm in the Christmas spirit
I have never seen a frame I've never
seen a clip a trailer a mini thing on
YouTube I've never seen anything about
that have you I haven't the slightest
clue I have no idea what we're walking
into but I've been bombarded forever to
watch it so I was like all right here we
go gonna do it guys smash that like
button and as always full length three
action watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy of RR available for
our super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page we also covered exclusively several
shows over their reaction Heights and
watch alongs included I'll move
reactions you see here full length watch
Longs over there I hear it's exciting
I've had people at parties be like you
should do RR so apparently it's an
exciting film no idea what we're going
to get into right now but let's see
[Music]
there's white people in this yeah I
think this is uh Brits uh it's amazing
Who's the artist
I want to have this little package on
our mantelpiece Edward yes sir
okay
there we go
[Applause]
oh
Jesus
no do you comprehend the value of the
bullet in your Barrel
it was manufactured in an English
Factory using English Metals it crossed
the seventh season in English vessel
by the time it reached the barrel of
Yorkshire
it cost one pound
one pound sterling and you would want to
squander it on
Brown rubbish ouch damn clear the road
[Music]
oh Jesus oh my God
oh
why
oh wow the production design on this is
gnarly that's powerful
[Music]
that's a great shot you should recruit
this guy
arrest that buster
bring him
to me
[Music]
got into the crowd rest that one guy
[Music]
but throw down
oh my god oh dude
Mr Officer what are you doing
[Applause]
ah
damn this guy's
deal
it's a claustrophobic wow he's in a man
cave
oh oh
my God he's gonna really make his way
out this crowd he's gonna he's gonna
finish that assignment
laughs
I think I want to understand is why is
he fighting so hard for the Brits I know
oh
jeez Louise oh God
[Music]
he's powered by Vengeance and good
mustache jeans
oh
that's cool that's a beautiful shot the
fire is reflective of this man's passion
[Music]
trouble then very good
why are those buckets labeled fire
oh [ __ ]
to put out fires oh right back to his
post
foreign
[Laughter]
contribution they are Philip Anderson
Charles Langford Frank Pooh
you gotta be [ __ ] me wow
[Music]
The Swinging on that rope actually saved
him time no but it looked cool yeah
damn there's some gnarly visuals
oh no no
that's awesome
foreign
[Laughter]
together
you can do it
Flex like you've never flexed before
now you can really tie it together
actually knock it out oh my God just
those claws alone right
[Music]
oh
damn thing won't stop
removed something earlier and attached
it now so you can charge me again
you cheating bastard you have no idea
who you're messing with man we have a
hunter
to roaming free we have nothing on him
you mean nothing it's quite an
impossible task how the hell are we
supposed to catch him the one that
accomplishes The Impossible
um
will be promoted to the rank of special
officers where's my stash boy do you
want him dead or alive
there he is
there's Mustache Boy
are you hitting him like that he's
forgotten his ID mom that doesn't give
you the right
can animals sorry ma'am
is good
she's beautiful
hey we're watching the ploy that he's
playing at
you
damn
wow how are they doing a shot
super drone
well he's somewhere in that region
[Laughter]
oh
that's not good
holy God Jesus
it's going to hit that child whoa
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nope
I don't have the slightest clue
[Music]
okay
[Music]
cool
yikes awesome hell yeah he's gonna catch
him with the flag
oh they're gonna trade
[Music]
oh dope
[Music]
cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh God that will last forever
this is just the beginning
hey rise for revolt
Brothers
[Laughter]
oh my God they're gonna work together
yeah I thought they're gonna fight this
is better
[Music]
I mean he's got to be like trying to
work his way up the ranks in some way to
get
he must have some type of vet and data
mission right
seems that way
I love this friendship is if you don't
squat you're homie you're not really
friends
[Music]
bang the white lady bang the colonizer
two motorcycles we're gonna throw these
needles at her get her attention yeah
throw them playground rules here just be
really mean to her proper tires
I think they're gonna do that yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we're such Rascals you're just gonna pop
some tires for fun
[Music]
they watch as 10 men mugger
[Laughter]
instead of put it in a terrible yeah
it's the perfect plan
[Laughter]
North poor tram station nearby huh
oh are you going that way
[Music]
I'm sorry I can't understand what you're
saying
he wants to go inside your home and make
a love to you and you have his children
passionately
oh don't call me memsaab it's just Jenny
yes
[Music]
Jenny yes
[Music]
just Jenny is
[Laughter]
it it's not for me there is a small girl
staying with us
Molly
[Laughter]
I love the music dude
foreign
what's he about to make
oh
a bracelet
wow that was really fast
[Music]
how beautiful
she's going to love it there is a party
at the Gymkhana Club
hmm
yeah baby please do try to come
bye you will learn English in the next
few hours
I will study diligently Aaron will also
learn English I will
fix it before
[Laughter]
a bangle
[Music]
it's a clue
hell yeah
they go
uh Feb 14th it's Valentine's Day if
you're in need of a dance partner
Jennifer
you need to look any further
I'm your perfect looking at the best
dance around him I second that
oh
dorky isn't how small he is
um let's join the party you bought carry
on I'll join you in a while
a pipe I love how this whole movie he
was full of Fury until he met him
a guy he's neither bro yeah
would you like to dance
oh this is where you speak the love
language
oh he knows how to dance you have no
idea he's about to make a literal hole
in that dance floor baby I run from
tigers in the jungle yeah I Dance with
the Devil
I'm sorry
[Music]
oh no you hurt a white woman
whatever dance off oh snap
oh dang let's get this [ __ ] on the road
man let's go let's go
show them up show them up come on can
you do
it break dance
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah baby go
[Music]
let's go support your brother hunting
[Music]
it always starts with the Bob not salsa
not Flamenco my brother
do you know
Desi Notch homie's so Suave dude
yes hell yeah
hey
yes look at him go look at him go
hey
yes
look at him Joe
oh they are perfectly safe
[Laughter]
this is the best
Series
this song right
can't hang homie
what are they gonna do what are they
gonna do
yes oh my God hey
blues for her lose Elevate him elevate
your brother don't [ __ ] block him
which is what he does with the tiger oh
we can go home now
why don't you carry me like that
you know what
he's got a bad cramp can you drop him at
a new buzzer of course of course
yeah
they're barely even sweating would you
like to come to my place it's almost so
much like Roseburg before I drop you
home
Molly
yo you've lost sight of the mission the
prize man there's a oh my God he's about
to put together right now
oh please don't put it together right
now right in this moment
wait how was it got the color of the
thing
is
[Music]
that's not our guy no no but it's the
first guy who um earlier in the movie
when he was chasing him yeah yeah when
they're at the gate
oh there's that anger there's that Fury
open the gate
[Music]
be cool man be cool servants could not
use the main entrance man he is not a
servant
friend let him go
As You Wish ma'am can't wait for these
people to die
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll break it down you know how to do it
[Music]
foreign
jungle
oh [ __ ] oh no
it's got beautiful fingernails oh
it's really confused there for a second
I was like he's really nice
you did mention that this must be this
must be his backstory to it somehow this
will get him back to her right as this
has got to be the reason why he's doing
this
the real question snake get me out of
here snake come on come on snake bro
snake bite through this for heaven's
snake get me out of here
got him that was really good timing man
hiker today
[Music]
whoa whoa damn oh damn he got him
it's pretty calm about this
[Music]
oh no notice him
oh you got me [ __ ] me noticing
oh it's frustrating jungle
gotta go back hi
he's got a great run
[Music]
foreign
damn
together
oh no
[Music]
uh you better remember this all right
when you're fine
foreign
[Music]
you're fighting the wrong guy
oh poor guy
[Music]
oh my God I thought they were sneaking
right nope oh they are no snake eat it
here
I did not see that coming this is like
some original Jungle Book [ __ ] right
here all right
[Music]
go spread murder
murder Mayhem
no wrong person
[Music]
yo this movie is bastardly added yeah
very well done there's like 4 million
shots slap the [ __ ] out of it
that's what I'm talking about
oh
it's right whip him how does it feel
does it feel to be whipped by chains huh
how does it feel I like the way you
scream
Jesus
[Applause]
yep our boy it's our other boy no it's
like Revelations up in here
oh come on is he back to the stash come
on man he's a man of the mission you
both didn't know he's like freaking Four
Horsemen
[Music]
um
oh my god oh come on surrender
Ken he really can't look him in the eyes
huh
[Music]
oh
my God
oh my God
[Music]
oh here we go
Jesus oh my God oh my God go for the
kill shot of there
whoa whoa
[Applause]
damn this is amazing choreography
damn that's an epic ass shot
it's like Mortal Kombat over here this
is so sick
ouch oh my God how is this foot more
powerful than
do it you know you can't do it you love
them you also can't bring him in dad
remember
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me that is so
messed up
instead of bringing bad luck
[Music]
[Applause]
jeez what a shot oh my God
the blood infection doing that man hey
Rama Raju is being awarded the rank of
special officer
got what you wanted hope you're happy
was it worth it Raju they'll squats me
nothing squatted you man
you dance together
[Music]
oh now it's a flashback yes I know
[Laughter]
tomorrow
oh my god did he send his son in there
to be like the ultimate undercover guy
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God what that turned so fast
we scared him sir thank God
yikes got him in the finger and the back
yeah baby
show them how it's done
[Music]
oh
no no no no no no no no no no no
oh you gotta be kidding me you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no no
oh no
Lord
[Music]
okay I'm gonna leave him there it is
oh in the face
[Music]
got it yeah she's playing a real long
game here yeah
exactly yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
of Daring to rise against us
and begs for Mercy this music is great
too no
it's really come this far
foreign
Jesus lady
oh he's making him Bend he didn't kneel
she has to die first
oh he was making sure it didn't Neil
officer
[ __ ] Passion of the Christ
[Music]
come all right so you gotta be motivated
in some way
[Music]
Jesus Christ
damn oh [ __ ]
oh my God
that's awful rise
[Music]
there we go yep
it is didn't realize it they're wanted
to make an example out of it and the
opportunities give more fuel
foreign
[Music]
yes and what was blatantly obvious was
your abject failure at bringing this
brute to his knees
I'm sorry sir
[Music]
what did you do we'll find out it'll
come in handy right
okay perfectly slid that in there
very good it's a fascinating world it's
like starting to question the rules like
this but the movie imagined to be like
so serious too
go faster
I said faster damage
oh [ __ ] yeah oh he's gonna grab that gun
isn't it here damn
[Music]
what the hell what the [ __ ]
you gotta be kidding me no no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] face smashes on these men all
right it's brutal man
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's not what you think it is homie
no
[Music]
oh he has no idea
oh
no no
oh next to his head next to his head
right
he'll be so starving he'll be gnoring at
his chains
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about yeah
damn okay well I'm in a solitary cell
[Music]
ouch
yes
get it
to everyone
[Music]
oh [ __ ] she came over here in
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shoot
oh my God really
sacrificed himself huh
damn that
is a haunting memory right there to kill
his own dad [ __ ] man but he became a
great dancer along the way
not if he can stop it
gotta save his boy in return
he's dancing the pattern the Rhythm yes
[Music]
[Music]
Brothers yeah
let's do this
[Music]
fight is one
go oh my God it's so sick
crap
that's incredible yes do it man yes
they're one Superman oh [ __ ] oh cool
yes
it's gnarly yes
I love it I love it so much
[Music]
this is awesome oh my God
oh
yeah
go yay
oh my God they're becoming a centipede
he's gonna flip him up there
oh yes
yes they've just had no [ __ ] yeah
one shot that's what we're talking about
my man
hahaha
this is so insane
so creative
[Music]
yes I love it I love it oh man
[Music]
he just knows an herb for every
situation
you don't even know where he's at dude
oh it's so
sickness
hell yeah
oh
oh holy God
[Music]
yikes right in the jugular
sick wow that's beautiful yeah
though you saw the bridge scene yeah
they don't need words shoot hey
nice
oh
no [ __ ] way
that's what I'm talking about it's like
What's it gonna do
are we just gonna grab it all right all
right
[Music]
ah the reprisal hell yeah
look at them go I love that twist under
the the horse that was amazing
yes Ghost Rider
this is TNT oh yeah
amazing
oh they're destroying the British Empire
oh my God
why'd you go inside when did you go
inside he's trying to get guns for
everyone
it's a little too late for that man
is that my blood
he's moving
oh this hurts
your sadistic wife is dead sucks too so
whoa she's like covered in the barbed
wires and everything
the weapons for all the villages
yes
oh the bullet bullets the bullet Lord
oh
this is great this is so cathartic this
is great
[Music]
I love that they're the best
the greatest chemistry
ah they finally get to be together
friendship
[Laughter]
[Music]
he really does look like a warrior I
mean he pulls off the long hair really
well it pulls his full of every look
he's had in this you know Screw you man
you can look like both it's not fair it
pulls up both looks too well
oh yeah her story right here yeah a
little focus on rap stories she's gotta
get her back home that's right
[Music]
beautiful
wonderful
all right
wow
okay I'll listen to Netflix I'll just
watch something else now
but on Wednesday
just keep it rolling same video three
hours why don't you just watch something
else bullet trains only on Netflix what
that was awesome
dope dope let's talk about it after I go
to the bathroom really
alrighty okay well
didn't look up anything in that bathroom
[Laughter]
breaks I've hit a record we're going we
just went so blind with this I was like
keep it blind keep it blind just go from
here uh it was fascinating going into
this because like I said I hadn't seen
like a a frame of this movie before
watching it but you know the talk I
always heard was like this film was
crazy this film's wild you gotta watch
this movie it's crazy and so my
preconceived notions before watching it
were that it's like it's just going to
be three hours of just insane visuals
and action scenes from beginning to end
like this is what I thought based off
the way everyone
described the experience of this movie
and to me I'm like well it's not that at
all like I mean like they have their
sequences that are like crazy you know
that don't get me wrong they have
secrets that are like so visually
expression it and insane and enthralling
like obviously like without a doubt but
it's not this like non-stop chaotic
thing that the way how people have sort
of like talked this movie up in that
regard doesn't like this movie is
actually a lot deeper than than anyone
like no one literally nobody no and when
you heard about this wasn't it that's
not like mainly what you would hear like
this movie was crazy it's like three
hours of the non-stop actions
they go long stretches without action
they go like very long stretches I could
probably count on like like a couple of
hands and I heard nobody talk about the
dancing yeah that's true I mean it's a
Bollywood movie so I guess you would
expect that but I've never seen and my
brother jabby Coy obviously very much in
that whole International Market but this
is my first um I think this is my first
feature film out of and I'm afraid to
get this wrong because I know a lot of
times you get these regions all messed
up and it can offend him and we don't
intend to just look at this as dumb
Americans okay
um but yeah the a first Indian movie
Bollywood film ever experienced uh me
personally you yourself too so I've
never watched one before not for camera
or just in my own life so they must all
be the same and they must all be this
way right right all of them are three
hours long and they're all exactly like
this
biggest Market in all in the in the
entertainment field yeah
um but no I mean for a first time
experience with that I thought it was a
lot deeper than because it deals so much
with the anti-colonialism and Grand like
my history is not the sharpest when it
comes to this stuff but you know it you
can pick up on it even if you're not
super familiar with it obviously dealing
with the the British Empire rule and
then it's it's a story about overcoming
oppression and coming together and also
you know you have these two guys on uh
who are fighting for the same cause
anti-colonialism they're fighting for
the same cause and they you know one's
more tribal and one's more westernized
culture uh indoctrinated into it and
then by the end of it it's like they
learn through the Revolutionary Ways and
through the causes that it's kind of
have to be a blend of both well they're
revolting you know and I think it was
kind of a really cool personal story
I think I did hear forever ago because
we were saying this in between filming
that it might you made it joke is it
based on a true story but I actually
heard him it might be based on a true
story I did hear that like it must be
inspired by something true because
obviously like it seems like
historically like I don't know exactly
what in that final dance number everyone
it's showcasing I don't know anyone
they're really showcasing there because
yeah my history on the on that side is
is not that large
um but obviously it was like this must
be in reference to real life people you
know these must be real life people and
uh who who did stand up against all this
[ __ ] they had to deal with but it is
so much more than just bang bang cool
sweet visuals and it's neat to get a
movie that has so much of uh about like
real life War themes happening
throughout but then also to combine it
with some of that 80s like action cheese
in a way that looks super sweet so yeah
man yeah dude I just think that
we talked you talked a lot about how
everyone talked about how crazy it was
in terms of action I think the thing
that surprised me the most was how much
hard it had and the relationship between
the two main characters I never I've not
seen a bromance that strong in a movie
and I don't know how long and you know
it was really heartbreaking watching
these two guys come to head because
you're just even though there's a song
at the beginning of the movie that kind
of foretells the things are gonna happen
even when it is happening you're just
like no you guys are so great together
you guys just had a dance number and you
like you do squats and
and you're riding motorcycle
that came back around like at the
beginning this is like it's just kind of
funny and then it comes into playing the
in the big rescue scene yeah
hilarious and it's badass and yeah man I
think it really told a story and it
really made you dislike and have like a
a bitter resentment towards the the
British and the and anticholonialism and
I think that watching these two guys
come together in the end super
satisfying in spite of the fact that you
know I for the most part I didn't really
feel the run time I was just kind of
super invested in everything that was
going on and yeah like three hours
no it didn't feel like three hours I'm
like two and a half
that's exactly yeah
but yeah dude I think that you know I
what really made the movie for me was
like the music the music and the sound
design was incredible in this the stunt
work was incredible in this movie like
all of the the different wire work and
how creative they were with the action
scenes it was like yeah it's you can
tell that
I think it was a what my takeaway is
like great action and great storytelling
is international it's made everywhere
Grant obviously I've we've both watched
foreign films on this channel before I
don't watch as many foreign films as I
would like to uh in my personal life but
I think doing stuff like this with Greg
really kind of opens my eyes up to the
different types of of film that's out
there you know and the way they they
utilize the camera and the way that they
utilize slow motion
to uh to kind of elevate their
storytelling and yeah just you see that
they Infuse both their culture with this
uh with the way that they elevated their
characters for example like the the
dancing scene with them having the dance
off so he's kind of wing Manning so his
boy can get the girly at the end of the
day and I was just like I thought that
was a very clever use of using something
that's traditional in more Indian films
to kind of I don't know Grand I don't
know if how they're used in other films
but I was just like that's that's
[ __ ] smart I like that yeah uh yeah I
think there's just a lot of really
clever uses of
of uh all the things all the stuffs yeah
oh yeah super no it's a massive
technical achievement in in every regard
because like cinematography wise
everything really pops it's gorgeous it
looks like it was filmed on like IMAX
cameras or something because you can see
that the way that I I really love IMAX
cameras and there's Parts about it that
felt like did they shoot this on on that
type of HD lens
um but yeah the everything really popped
and it is very imaginative
and it is so many different styles and
tones all meshed into one yeah and it
flows uh it's kind of like a very
different movie but I would use similar
nouns and adjectives to describe is like
everything everywhere all at once yup
like this is wild and I've never seen
anything quite like it and it's a bunch
of different things on a big blender and
somehow it all communicates well and I'm
never laughing at the movie you know
exactly and I and I felt some kind of a
similar experience here you know and
especially to get that that Bollywood
dance number when
um beam is with uh Jenny and and then
they go into the Bollywood dance number
I thought that was such a a beautifully
executed sequence and you felt like you
felt like to pump me up about it you
know because it took me a little bit of
time to be like okay what exactly is
this movie what exactly where exactly is
this going but when they do come
together when they do like touch
Brothers in Arms you know like it's
about how they have to unite together
and embrace their different parts of
where they come from within the same
hemisphere here that that is the thing
that could lead to Conquest over this
oppression and so that's the journey
like that's a deeper part of this
journey you know and I think it's kind
of a beautiful story like there's it's
actually a beautiful story in a lot of
ways so I get why this resonated so much
more Beyond just like it's a big Indian
film like it it seemed to really make
its way over to here and I was kind of
surprised just because I I've never
heard of it and I never even saw a
trailer for it but seeing what this
movie is now I'm like no I could get it
because you know we've we have our own
dealings with uh with Wars in history
and I feel like themes about
anti-colonialism and oppression and and
overcoming the racism and all that like
all those things we've I think that's a
universal thing as much as this is very
specifically tied to the Indian culture
and the history those subjects and
feelings that can be a very Universal uh
attainable feeling that we all can sort
of connect to in some way shape or form
and I think this movie really hits that
Mark Strong because they keep it as an
intimate story between the two of them
and I love the arc like I really like
beam a lot like he's great he kind of
reminds me of an anime character yeah
just like this who's ever like shocked
by things like every time he's like a
reveal happens you know an anime
character is always like
whenever something
yeah you'd make a great reaction Channel
um yes but
um the IMDb is kind of confused you have
IMDb full in front of us I thought his
name was RAM for the subtitles wrong
Netflix was kind of bugging out on us
when we were watching yeah a little bit
I mean
right there yeah but I thought sometimes
the subtitles his name was Ram it was
the actor's name oh yeah that's what it
says on IMDb but in the subtitle
sometimes it said RAM on the subtitles
that's weird Netflix is tripping Netflix
was was bugging out on us while we're
watching I'm like well there's only so
much we can do because Netflix is wrong
I think they I mean let me just type
this RR character names let me just look
here let me just look here
um of course they don't have his name
the one guy's name I'm looking for right
now is the one not the name not listed
right now Rama Rama right
that's what was confusing me sometimes
the subtitle said that
because the subtitles couldn't be
contained by the sheer epicness of the
movie that it got confused that's the
only logical explanation for why it
would mix things up because it was like
oh it's amazing but look right here what
uh uh Sita
Rama raju's fiancee
no I'm saying they're like maybe that
was like his
I don't know it's weird that it would
have one no it's the same characters
yeah I'm a little bit confused
Beyonce but it's not in his his actual
like legal name I suppose it was using a
fake name when he was in the British uh
I don't know we picked up on the main
things we did that's the main thing that
matters uh Rama Raju
I think it's I think that's his name
Rama so yeah with Rama like his
character portrayal I thought was great
because it is such an at odds and it is
that kind of relatable story of the
detective who goes so far undercover
that he loses sight of everything and
has to get nasty and dirty but beyond
that you know it's someone who like I
love the goal at hand was he had to go
that far into the into the the depths of
it all and or and no matter what went in
his way nothing nothing could get in the
way of that and he had to provide guns
for his villagers put a weapon in front
of it for his whole all his people
and uh watching that Journey that it's
not worth sacrificing certain
it's not worth sacrificing people though
for it you know and this and like their
friendship mattered above all there's
also like a really fun movie and cool
like it's kind of crazy because people
talk so much about how gnarly of an
experience this movie was and it is an
experience but I feel like not enough
people talk about like no it's an actual
story
it's a real movie with a real plot and
real characters yeah and a real journey
and real themes and real life subjects
they're dealing with and everyone just
talks about like the there's like
there's not it's not the action stands
out but I wouldn't say out of three
hours it's like a lot of action I think
the character stuff stands out more than
the action in my opinion I think maybe
they're about on par I think the coolest
thing about the movie for me is the fact
that it is able to have this crazy wild
action yet when it's happening even
though it's ridiculous you still buy
into the stakes of what they're doing
yeah and you still care and you're still
rooting for them because you've invested
so much time with them when when the
movie is grounded that by the time
things are going bananas you're just
you're just cheering or you're having
high emotional reactions because we
really didn't want to see them fight
when they when they stormed the the
British Castle or whatever and you
really didn't want to
see them come to head when he was when
he was whipping him you know and I
thought that was a powerful scene
watching him kind of sing the song and
like not bending the knee in front of
all the people and inspiring them I was
like man like we need to see like some
of that stuff in more movies it kind of
reminded even though it's it's the
opposite side of the world like some of
their aspects of it that reminded me of
like American slavery and and like
obviously the whipping and like the knee
and other aspects surrender me of Jesus
you know uh like inspiring people and
like being like the Martyr to get the
people to revolt and I think that it's
it's cool that both of them had this
goal to do it but but neither of them
saw it and they end
in some ways there was like this this
unspoken kinship before they knew each
other's intentions and maybe that was
part of what bonded them because they
sensed each other's each other's Souls
you know and I think that
yeah the movie really demonstrates a lot
of cool callbacks and symbolisms like
the whole necklace thing like they each
they each had to reveal a realization
when they saw the necklaces on each
other's person and yeah and
yeah it was just a lot of really cool
stuff the music really really worked for
me my music was brilliant brilliant it
really drove to help Drive The Narrative
that much further well I think like you
know
uh one represents fire and one
represents water and you and they are
such opposites that Clash but the whole
point is that you're supposed to be a
blend of both together yeah and it's
kind of like the movie Inside Out
can't have uh can't have joy without
sadness you know
just watched it it's fresh I know so
everything's gonna relate to inside out
for the next six months now okay
I definitely see and see what you mean
about everything ever all at once
because it did have a lot of those
elements to it as well you know the
balance of Comedy the balance of drama
the balance of action the the
Celebration The Whimsy of it all the
comedy yeah yeah cartoonish nature yeah
it's just a well-balanced film a
well-balanced breakfast I'm full I feel
I feel good after watching it and
the guy plays Raja man I thought he was
freaking brilliant both of them are
great yeah they're both great the Raja
guy though it's like he's he just has
that they both command the screen but he
commands the screen I mean he got the
more I think he got the more interesting
character you know like it's the one
with the real conflict and the real like
messed up past you know that's it was
crazy watching his whole family die yeah
and sacrifice his father and like and
that like that's like a core wound
memory I can say that it's a core
remember for uh of like not don't let
anything get in the way like that he was
at that moment that that's the moment
that defined him and the journey that he
put on and he had to learn along the way
like maybe you shouldn't operate like
this since yeah you know
um but yeah I thought it was beautiful I
think there's a lot of beautiful things
about it and I think the the way this
movie's composed overall like it's
really well thought out and calculated
in the symmetry of the shots like the
the editing of this it just seems like a
nightmare to me to try to put this movie
together I'm like this seems like a vast
headache because as much there's like
crazy visual effects with like the
animals and
you know certain other key moments that
look beautiful I really liked how
how much of the production design felt
like oh you got real extras here you got
real like weapons here you got real
costumes you know like you got real set
pieces I thought that was great to bring
it all to life too to mix it with the
with the CGI that way it feels more
attainable and I think that's what helps
have something that's heightened but
believable when you when you mash the
two together so I thought it was
gorgeous to look at and it just made for
a really interesting experience and then
unlike any other movie I've seen so
sorry I've put it off for so long but
here we are Merry Christmas made it
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas it's a
universal time for a lot of us here and
um yeah I'm not sure if there's I think
we did it I think we did I think we
talked about the main things we wanted
to mention here checked all the boxes
it was fun great stuff everything was
great everything was great maybe the
women characters could have been fleshed
out a little bit more
we could have got more Jenny could have
got more of um
yeah I think it's her name both of them
we need more both of them I mean I like
them I thought they were good but I
don't know the movies it was about the
two guys thought of romance Brotherhood
this is good let's go oh and the Ray
Stevenson was a good villain too he
really I think him being the the bait
the main Baddie was um
a good call because he had that right
level of
he wasn't too over the top but it was
like just cheeky enough and the wife was
like she was like devious oh she's the
worst she's the worst she's the villain
she was like he wouldn't have done half
the things he did if it wasn't it's the
woman's problem it's the woman's fault
why the man messed up
was this world coming to
since this is the 1800s woman a big good
strolling man
or 1900s 19 with eight hours nine this
could be 1900 it could be like before
World War II a little bit before 1920s
that's right here 1920 1920. okay yeah
all right we figured that out
of that right before this video alrighty
guys well thank you for being here be
sure to uh subscribe click that Bell
leave a like what did you think of RR
um last but not least Aaron I wanted to
do a pick
Brandon Benzie hello
hello it's a friend Aaron here I'm here
to tell you thanks for being a great
Patron you know I know this guy isn't
giving enough love you know I haven't
given you enough love I didn't even know
you existed until like four seconds ago
but I just want to say you were loved
and you were appreciated and buy
yourself something nice this Christmas
you know get those sandals you always
wanted or that massage gun or that
weighted blanket you know you really
want that weighted blanket I want that
weighted blanket you know maybe if we
can like split it somehow like I'll send
you some money and then you can like
ship it to me sometime anyway that's
beside the point uh we just want to
thank you for being a great Patron and
for supporting the channel and you're a
superstar you're loved and Greg's gonna
get you a Christmas gift personally
this is the gift this is this is the
gift Aaron shouting you what you really
wanted when you pledge to this patreon
for a shout out
was that Aaron shouts you out
I know I know he told me and I was like
I'm honored of course yeah I got you
buddy
I got you we're gonna we're gonna make
great things happen next year enjoy
those slippers I'm gonna ask you I'm
gonna ask you in a month if you remember
who we shouted out in RR if you're like
Brandon Benzie of course I'm gonna give
you I'm gonna give you five dollars okay
all right
you heard that you heard that Ben five
dollars coming right Brian Benson you
heard that Brandon I mean Aaron what no
refunds Brennan
Christmas
thank you they know in Austin Saturday
thank you Brandon for being you've been
for a part of our page for uh like a
good amount of time already like uh most
of 2022 so thank you and thank you for
helping us in 2022 on a strong note
buddy Merry Christmas Happy New Year
thank you